The waiting.
Oh, I'd love that.
Oh my God, you all right?
Due to an earlier injury,
Dan is currently nursing his wound
with a bit of water,
but this video is about barbecue.
A lot of people like to barbecue,
you know, steak burgers,
sausages,
maybe even cook some ribs.
Yeah, tasty.
We like to barbecue with butane gas.
Jesus, get it.
That was
Awesome.
Where did it go?
I have no idea.
Just a sliver.
It just didn't come back down.
It just went up like a rocket,
didn't it?
It was so forceful it
blew out all the flames
and didn't even make a fireball.
If we want it to ignite.
Perhaps what we should do is have
some barbecues about two
meters away next time.
And so it will blow up and then
maybe we'll revisit this one
in future.
Yeah.
Well, where the hell did it go?
Maybe it's an orbit. Is it in space?
Where did that-
I want to see where that went.
And your grandparents were inside?
Probably wondering what
this good do what the
scudush was.
What was that?
Okay.
Maybe a,
maybe a butane barbecue
is not such a good idea.
Doesn't taste good.
Alright, here's take two.
We're going to do that again
with a few modifications.
I'm gonna stand over here.
Whoa!
It's gonna be good.
Look at all that black smoke.
You nervous?
No.
I was nervous with a diet Coke and Mentos,
but not with this.
Good.
You nervous, you all right?
Look at him behind the wall.
A scared schoolboy.
I heard various explosions earlier.
Various explosions.
Dan, let's drop some science
on some of this.
Alright.
Let's figure out what's going on.
It does go fast, isn't it?
I don't know were any of them landed.
I think heard one of
them around behind me.
Cause it went that way.
I thought it ended up in the field.
I don't think every one went that way.
I wish we had a camera on the ground
just pointing up.
She's done that.
Maybe do that again.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's try and figure out,
because right.
That block is just hovering
in the air for ages.
And at this point,
the can is like, up there somewhere.
So that can shows you
how slow we're actually recording.
How many- how many frames was that?
It was 2005 frames per second.
So that's a hundred times then
That's a hundred times
slower than playback
and that is fast.
So let's- we can figure
out how fast it's going.
Okay.
How, how big would you say that was?
Yeah, it was probably
about that big, isn't it?
Well from there, maybe three meters?
Something like that?
Um
Yeah.
Okay. So say three meters.
I love that.
Watch that.
There's no, there's no scalable.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you've got the timer.
Okay. We got 16 seconds.
Okay.
One, two.
Okay. About three seconds.
Three seconds,
three seconds, three meters.
So what?
So right now in real time,
it took three seconds.
So in real time,
that was naught point naught
three of a second real time,
second.
360,000
Divide that by a thousand
because we didn't meet it.
Yet.
And that gives us the kilometers,
which is
360,
But Siri,
It's not 4S.
Convert 360 kilometers into miles.
[Siri] This might answer your question.
223 miles an hour.
All right.
That is a fast can.
That's like a sports car.
Lads, don't put cans of
butane on your barbecue.
Or girls, don't do that either.
If we did that calculation
completely wrong,
do feel free to let us know.
But yeah.
See if you come up with similar figures,
That was very approximate as well,
I'd have to say.
Roughly.
Roughly, 3 years.
Roughly three years,
roughly three seconds, but yeah,
over a hundred miles an hour, definitely.